608 now and in-person services are back
this morning at the vegas pbs resource
library our hector mejia live inside the
library with how they're helping people
living with disabilities hi hector good
morning to you
hey there alex good morning you know
this is great news families with
special needs already go through a lot
now imagine having to
buy resources books materials that are
usually
more expensive than the typical ones so
here they provide about fourteen
thousand resources at no cost to
families not just here in clark county
but across the whole state and if
families can't make it here
they can ship it to their homes this is
one of the 14 000 items
this is arthur and this is for uh for
for people who
may not be able to see correct correct
it is for
children with visual impairments in fact
if you press
that little backpack here we go
his backpack and sneakers are red arthur
has rosy cheeks and a big friendly smile
a big friendly smile for a child with a
vision impairment they might
be able to feel of course but they might
not be able to see that the sweater is
yellow
or that arthur wears glasses or that he
has blue jeans on
so that is channel 8's own nate
tannenbaum's
son wow from long ago from long ago
probably about 12 years ago he helped us
develop this
family literacy kit based on arthur
and his sister dw and hector it's all
about
continuing the learning beyond the
programming beyond the fabulous programs
that our children watch on tv
we also have these activities for
parents to extend the learning
right into their living rooms and it's
ongoing no matter where
and part of pbs dna is making sure
all students all have access to media
regardless if they have a disability or
not and this is dr nikki bates
and we were just chatting earlier just
about all the resources and uh
for those families the materials are
normally more expensive to get
for uh let's say just a puzzle or a book
or a movie
exactly a puzzle a normal puzzle
at walmart might be five dollars but if
it is
specifically adapted for a student or a
child or an adult
that might have fine motor disabilities
then it is going to be two to three
times as expensive
so being able to provide those adapted
resources instructional resources here
for parents
is a huge service to the community for
those that would otherwise not be able
to afford it so the in-person services
were closed during the thick of the
pandemic and you guys slowly started to
reopen
being able to provide curbside pickup
which by the way is still available
right now
for those families watching from home no
cost to the families
however you do need to make an
appointment is that correct oh
absolutely please
buy appointment only because we do want
to ensure proper
procedures in following the cdc
guidelines so by appointment only and
you can call 702-799-1010
option 7 to make an appointment to come
in to browse the library
dr bates thank you very much for your
time and as you can see
14 000 items a lot so we'll be talking
a little bit more about those still
ahead of the next half hour for now
reporting live hector mejia
8 news now back to you guys such good
stuff and i love
that guy nate's son did that john
uh hector that is so cool
it's really cool isn't it really cool
good job to guy
a yellow friend and he did that when he
was even younger so it's not impressive
all right thank you talk about a
throwback i know